ERIC BIDELMAN: Thanks, man.
Bet you didn't
know you were going
to join a revolution tonight,
but it's totally here.
The Web Components revolution.
I'm super excited about it.
I've been working on this stuff
for now a couple of years.
And-- I'm going to
bump this up for you--
my name is-- just so you
know who you're talking to.
Peter introduced me, but
I'll introduce myself again.
My name's Eric Bidelman.
I work on the Chrome team.
I work on Polymer.
I think Web Components
are the bee's knees.
It's going to change the
way we develop the web.
Hopefully by the
end of the night--
it's a long night--
there's going
to be lot of cool demos,
a lot of cool examples.
My goal to you tonight
is to sort of sell you
on the value proposition
of Web Components.
What problems it
solves, what issues
it's addressing in
web development.
I can't really spend enough time
on the lower level tech in 25
minutes, so feel free to
Tweet at me, Google+ me,
check out the HTML5
Rocks articles,
there's a lot of really good
stuff there to read about.
So what's the need
for Web Components?
Why are we having a four
hour event for you guys
to even groc all that?
And to really
understand where we're
going with Web
Components, you have
to actually understand
where we've been.
So once upon a time, I present
to you, the web, right?
This is how the web looked.
And we had a bunch of stuff
that we kind of pieced together.
Maybe some JavaScript
here, some HTML here.
And it was like this.
It was a mess, right?
It was coming from
all over the place.
And then, of course,
HTML5 came along.
This was like, this was going to
solve all our problems, right?
This is going to cure cancer.
It's going to solve world peace.
You know, and it did.
The industry got really,
really stoked about it
and we're still stoked
about it and stuff just
kept getting added and added.
And so we added WebRTC
and Web Audio API
and all these really
rich APIs in order
to have a more powerful
platform, and that's great.
But-- oh, no, his
T-rex head is cut off.
This is great, but it's
a lot of overkill for us
regular developers.
I'm a regular developer.
I don't need WebRTC
capabilities all the time.
What about my productivity?
What about useful stuff
for me to develop?
And so, the journey
starts in 2010.
Some really smart people--
Dimitri Glazkov actually I
call him one of the
godfathers of Web Components--
sent a note to the public
web apps mailing list.
This is the mailing lists for
general new stuff that's appy.
And he was like, hey,
I've been thinking
about this a long time
with some other folks.
We need things in the
platform-like template
and why can't we do proper
template in the browser?
Why does everybody
do it differently?
Shadow DOM, the ability to
actually scope and encapsulate
certain chunks of
markups on the CSS.
This is four years ago, right?
This has been a long, long
journey since this time.
But it's kind of
really interesting
to go back in the archives
and see this stuff actually
play out.
So what's happened?
So over the years, all these
specifications that there's
been a lot of contributions
too, they basically
say, hey, let's strip
the platform back.
Let's decide what are
the API parameters that
are really, really
useful for developers?
That are going to make
you, myself included,
very productive.
So let's take HTML5, let's
pull back the covers,
strip it down, and identify
the layers of the platform
that we really need
in order to make
it a really powerful product--
application building platform.
So this is where the Web
Component specs come in.
Let's add all this
really low level
stuff so it can enable the
next generation of frameworks
on the web.
Of course, developers
can tweak it.
They can do whatever
they want with it.
This stuff can be composed
and used together,
but that's really
where the power is.
We're getting all these tools,
and this utility belt for you
to develop the next
generation applications.
So Web Components.
What-- at its core,
the way I think of it
is a set of emerging standards.
It allows developers
to extend HTML.
It allows you to
say hey browser,
there's this new thing you
should know about essentially.
It's got functionality, it's
got API, it's got markup,
it's got CSS.
And wrap all that
up and deliver that.
Have other people use it.
So it's really, really important
that we kind of take away--
all the stuff you're going to
see today, all the stuff I'm
showing you, all the stuff
the great presenters that will
follow will show you it's
all based on these standards.
It's all W3C
standard, so it's not
some kind of proprietary thing.
It's stuff that you can use.
You can use the native
vanilla stuff if you want.
You can use the
Polymer for extra sugar
in your x-tags or
these other options.
That's really the
awesome bit about this.
And so the standards
involved here.
Four main standards when
you kind of break it apart.
The first is templates.
This is actually being able to
do proper DOM-based templating
in the browser.
So you could say, I want
this section of markup
to be used later, and
then stamp that out
as you create different
elements and components.
Custom elements.
This is sort of the
bread and butter.
Being able to tell the browser,
I want to create a new tag.
I want to create my awesome
button tag, or my xtabs tag.
Being able to tell the
browser about this tag
and give it an API that
everybody can tap into
is really what that's all about.
And Shadow DOM is sort of one
of these foundational pieces
that's, again, useful by
itself as all these APIs are.
But, it really allows us
to encapsulate and scope
the problem to your component.
So, for instance, if you
define CSS in a Web Component,
it's not going to bleed out.
This is great, right?
As an author, you
want some guarantees
that what you've
worked so hard on
is not going to just bleed
out into the outside world.
And then the page is
not going to effect
the way your component looks.
That's really important.
So you can stick markup in a
component-- in a CSS component,
you're guaranteed to have the
scoping to that component.
And the last one is one of
these sort of really, really
nice APIs, you've
never had before.
We should have.
HTML imports.
You can load up, you can bundle
your CSS and your JavaScript
and your HTML together, and
deliver that via a single URL
that somebody can use.
And then they can
use your component.
So that's really,
really cool, because we
can package all this stuff in a
single bundle and deliver that.
Support for this is totally
accelerating across the board.
This matrix a year
ago which was pretty
crappy to be quite
frank with you,
but today with polyfills
and the polyfills
the Polymer team has built, you
can actually use all this stuff
in any of these modern browsers.
So, the moral of story
is, there's no excuse
not to play with Web
Components in 2014,
and that revolution is here.
So those are the
standards, but I
want to focus now
on custom elements.
I think this is one of the
foundational pieces of what
Web Components is all about.
So in order to understand
custom elements,
you actually have to take
another voyage back in time.
So this is the web today.
At least what
google.com looks like.
Let's throw back to 1998.
This is what google.com
looked like in 1998.
It's totally primitive, right?
The buttons look crappy, there
wasn't any CSS really available
to us.
Larry and Sergey came up with.
This is what Google looked
like-- this is probably
what your web app
looked like, right?
The web was built on forms.
This was like an
app at the time.
And so you can put an input
on it, it's pretty cool.
And you can type in here.
This is neat.
There's a select
element on this form.
And this is kind of like the
first example of a component,
right?
I declare this on my page and I
get this native little browser
widget, this little
component control and I don't
know how it's done,
it just happens.
So that's cool.
What's going on there?
And of course, when
you submit this form,
somehow it magically
just posts to a server
and it does all this black
magic under the hood.
So it's doing stuff that is
transparent to me as a user.
OK, Selecty's going to
help us build this web app.
Selecty is Clippy's cousin.
He likes to jiggle around.
So back then, elements
were very declarative
and a really good example
again is this select element.
It's actually got a lot
of stuff built into it.
So let's take select,
let's look at it.
I declare it on my page.
I throw some option
elements in there.
And, again, all I get is this
really cool little widget
for free.
I don't write any
CSS or JavaScript.
This kind of just
happens for me.
And it's got this
hover state, it's
got this check box, and
this other UI around it.
So literally just by
declaring this on the page,
I get a component.
The first browser
made of component.
I can also configure this thing,
so it takes HTML attributes.
So if I put a disabled
attribute on the option,
or a selected attribute
on the option, boom.
This thing knows
what to do with that.
It knows how to render
that in a different way.
It does exactly what you expect.
You can read this
code and say, oh,
yeah, those first two or
three options are disabled
and that last one
should be selected.
So the important thing here
is it's still declared.
We're not writing new script
to set this or render anything.
It's literally just markup.
Selecty's super
excited about that.
We can ultimately change the
way this thing behaves just
by using attributes as well.
If you move attributes up to
the select tag-- give it a size,
give it multiple
attributes-- we don't really
even let you have a dropdown.
We have this multi-select
widget which is really cool.
So depending on how the user
wants to interact with this,
we can totally-- you
can represent itself
in different ways.
And again, that's all
transparent to us.
We don't know how
this is happening,
but it's just happening.
You can compose elements.
So what does that actually mean?
Well, select rate
it takes options,
like you saw in
the last example,
but it also does smarter stuff.
You can give it an
optgroup element,
and it itself can be
configured via attributes.
So now, exactly as
you'd expect, this
does something different
based on the children elements
it gets.
So now we have groupings
instead of just a straight drop
down list you could
also take this and put
in an entirely
different context.
I can take my select, which
is a component essentially,
and if I put that
in a form element,
this thing knows--
somehow the browser know
that it's going to get
submitted with this form
and it's going to include the
value that the user's chosen.
So what she's telling
us, in different contexts
it takes on different
responsibility,
so it's composable in
different contexts.
But not everything
makes sense in markup.
Certainly I'm not arguing that.
In certain cases,
you're going to want
to respond to certain
events, right?
This element happens
to fire a change event
with something
interesting happens.
Which is when the user
selects a new option.
It exposes properties
on its DOM interface
that don't really
make sense in markup.
You don't really think about
a selected index in markup.
What does that-- what would
that even look like or mean?
But you should be able to
poke at that maybe and tweak
in JavaScript to do
something interesting.
So the properties and
methods, it fires events.
These are really, really
core things to what
the bare bones elements
gave us at the time.
So what happened?
This sounds pretty good.
I don't know if it
sounds good to you guys,
but this is super easy to use.
I can read all that code and
know exactly what's going on.
Well, this happened.
This mess happened.
This is an example of
opening DevTools and seeing
what Gmail looks like.
One of the most complex
web applications out there.
And what happened was that
the HTML markup actually
didn't keep up with the time.
It didn't-- it wasn't expressive
enough for us developers
to actually describe the complex
applications we were starting
to build on the web.
So you end up with div
soup, and that's OK.
This has gotten us pretty far.
But can anybody read this and
they know what's going on?
I mean, maybe to
purposely obfuscate it,
but I certainly can't.
It's not maintainable, you don't
know what's going on, if you
can't-- its not descriptive
or semantic in any way.
And on the other
side of the fence,
this is a Google+
web application,
we just wrote just a
crap-ton of JavaScript,
I'll be completely honest.
This is the only thing
we had, as a tool,
to actually get the job done.
So we're in a sad,
sad state of affairs.
It's not just
complex applications.
If you take a look at, I think,
the quintessential example
of a component-- a
tab component, right?
Just a bazillion tab
components out there.
This is what happened over time.
So we had a bunch of markup.
We annotated it with
some IDs or something.
And at the bottom, we wrote
a little bit of script.
Just a little bit to say,
hey, render this thing
that I just threw
together as a tab somehow.
And it worked, right?
And over time, what
progressively happened
was each framework and library
and author just developed
different ways to do
the exact same thing.
So this is five different
ways to build a tab component.
Every API is different Every
way to do it is different.
As a developer,
I have to learn--
I have to buy and learn
this new API in a way
to do something when,
ultimately, what I
want is just a standard
way to create components.
So that is what Web
Components is all about.
The ability to actually
create a new element,
say x-tabs, make
it composable, make
it configurable via
attributes, tell
the browser about
this new thing.
And, as a user, who knows
what this is supposed to do?
Maybe it's not
obvious, but I think
it's supposed to be
a tabs widget, right?
And it's super descriptive
and you absolutely
know, just by
looking at the code,
just by looking at the markup,
what it's supposed to do.
So that's the example.
Let's take a look at,
actually, a real example.
The Polymer team through
together this Google Map
element.
And, how many people-- who
can guess what this does?
I don't even need to
describe it to you.
But I'll tell you what it does,
I'll show you what it does.
It renders a map, right?
It uses the maps
API under the hood,
but as a user of this
thing, all that I do
is just declare the on my page.
That's pretty sweet.
I don't have to know the
complexities of that API,
I don't have to
worry about loading
libraries, going through this
callback dances, all of that
is totally transparent
to me, abstracted
away inside of this component.
Again, just an
example of select,
we can configure this
to take attributes.
So same rules apply
to custom elements.
This map element, when we you
give it a lat and a longitude,
it knows under the hood to call
the map's API center itself,
and that's exactly
what you see there.
It's got a zoom attribute
that we give it,
so it knows to zoom at
level 15 when you set that
on the attributes and
declare that on your page.
This thing is composable.
So, inside the
Google Map element,
I can stick Google
map marker tags.
And this map element, it knows
how to deal with those tags.
It knows that it
should place a map
marker at this
lat and this long.
What's also cool
about this is I'm
using other parts of the
platform that already exists.
So, the title attribute, right?
This is a standard
HTML attribute.
I can use that since we're
just talking HTML and DOM-- can
use that on my own
custom elements as well.
You can see when I mouse
over this map marker,
it has the title home,
just as you expect, right?
So I'm using parts of the
platforms that already existed.
I don't have to reinvent
the wheel every time.
HTML5 drag-and-drop
is an absolutely mess.
I hate it, but you can actually
reuse it in this case as well.
It's kind of cool.
You can respond to the
draggable attribute.
And if it's true right under
the hood you can drag this pin,
and the back's API, of
course, is doing the work,
but I don't need to know that
as a user of this component.
I just rocked declarative
option, and boom,
I get the maps API.
Of course, you can add
further markup to this page
and it knows what to
adjust to the children.
A really common thing to
do actually in the API
that I wanted to
do for this demo is
as I add more markers
to this map owner,
I want to send her
those in the viewport.
And that's actually
a pretty common thing
to do in the map's API if you
guys ever played with it. ad
But it's a little
bit of boiler code,
and I had to actually
go and reread that stuff
and figure out how
to do that again.
So, instead what could
happen, if I have a marker
off the screen, I can expose
that as sort of a way for users
to configure this thing.
So when I have the shrink
to markers attribute on,
somebody declared that.
The map just knows-- and you
totally can't see it, sorry.
It's off-screen.
But it just knows to
center those two markers
on the screen.
And of course, if I add
new ones-- in this case,
you can see the dead
center of the map.
So, again, just by declaritively
configuring this custom
element, the map knows
what to do under the hood
and that's really,
really powerful.
So this could be the future
of how you use Google Maps.
At least I think
it's really exciting.
So what does this all enable.
You've see it, right?
You can be declarative again, we
can use HTML to a [INAUDIBLE].
We kind of pushed HTML under
the carpet for a long time,
but we can actually
rise it up, and it
can rise up to the occasion now.
We can make it do whatever we
want, which is really cool.
Things are composable.
In different contexts, you
can take a component here
and a component here.
Mash them together to
form a larger application.
So, again, you're not
reinventing the wheel
every time, you're
building stuff
and reusing stuff
somebody else has done.
Scoping-- this is huge.
CSS scoping, the ability to
actually define a component
with a section of CSS,
and not have it bleed out
or things bleed in, we've
never had that before.
And it's totally different
than the IFrame, too.
IFrames are crazy
complex and it's overhead
and it's hard to script into.
This is awesome, right?
You get CSS in capsulation,
DOM in capsulation,
and the ability to find an
API on a per-component basis.
So we're not building apps
in this global context
anymore where you've
thrown in libraries here,
JavaScript there,
and CSS over here.
You actually can
think about how--
like what is the
functionality you need
and how to get that job done.
So there's a lot of totally new
ways to develop for the web.
The first mind-bending
thing that I
had a wrap my head around was
it's a new way to use HTML.
And I think you've probably seen
some examples there already.
Well let's take a look
at what exists today
and then compare it to tomorrow.
So if you think
about HTML elements,
this is the standard kind
of stuff it is today.
You have things
like input, right?
You have the select.
We saw these before.
The progress tag,
this is pretty cool.
You get a little
rendering little progress
bar for free from the browser.
Text area button video controls.
All of these render
UI to the screen.
Something that users of
your website would see.
But there's this whole sort
of other side to elements
that people don't really
think about too much,
and it's really things
that developers see a lot.
These are all elements--
these are examples of elements
that don't actually
render any UI.
But what do they do?
They provide utility.
They do something.
We use them for some reason
on our page and in our app.
They don't actually
show anything.
So, for example, like if I
put a script tag in the page,
the browser knows whatever's
in that script tag
it's going to evaluate its
JavaScript and run that,
and it does something.
It serves a purpose.
It doesn't actually show
anything to the user.
And we could totally do the
same thing with custom elements,
right?
And this is sort of a
mind-bending thing like I said,
but we can define-- we can
wrap up pieces of functionality
that we're used to
using in JavaScript,
and actually provide a
declarative way to interact
with those services, those
APIs, and those libraries.
Really good example that we put
together on the Polymer team
was the core-ajax components.
I never have to write
boilerplate Ajax code again.
I just put this on the
page and I can use it.
I give it a URL, configure
it to be an attribute again.
I respond to some events, I'm
using my same bag of tricks,
right?
Querying the DOM, query
selector, and event listener--
this is the stuff I know how
to do as a web developer.
And the other example
here is geolocation.
I don't have to do a
crazy callback [INAUDIBLE]
I can wrap all that magic up.
Inside, an implementation detail
is totally transparent to me.
So non-visual custom elements.
That's pretty cool.
Interoperability.
Maybe people don't care
about interoperability,
but it's actually
the first time we
can have proper
interoperability on the web.
And I call it on by default.
So you get it for free if you
buy into this component model.
The fact that we're speaking
HTML team on DOM again.
Every framework, every
library, out there
on the planet, every developer
that has ever touched anything
on the web knows HTML5
and knows about DOM.
So it speaks that same language.
So what you can do is you
can pose different elements
together from all
over the place.
The x-tag's x-flip box
element, for instance.
I can put inside of
that a Polymer element.
And it's important
to know, it doesn't
matter that this element was
implemented using Polymer
and the other one is
implemented using x-tags.
The fact that they can
actually talk to each other--
because it's all
just DOM and it's
always HTML under the hood.
And then you can
use the same things
you use all over the place.
JQuery or querying the DOM,
or adding event listeners.
The stuff that we already
know as web developers
we can translate
into this new world.
DevTools support.
OMG, this is huge.
The tools know DOM.
The DevTools are really
good about DOM, right?
There's all this
power in the DevTools.
this is an example from our
home page, apolloproject.org.
It's a little tabs component.
When you click these tabs,
it changes the code snippet.
Really, really kind of
a trivial component.
But what's really neat is I
can query, I can open DevTools,
and since we're talking HTML
in DOM, it's all DOM-based,
I can drill at this and
I can inspect elements
and I can use the tools to
my advantage to debug issues.
I can bring up the console
and actually do live coding,
and query select
different things,
and change attribute
properties, and, as you can see,
I can update the selected
property under the hood.
So everything's live
because it's all in the DOM
and it's all just
speaking JavaScript.
I can use the DevTools to change
the styles of this element,
too.
Because it's just, again,
she's marked up the DevTools
and the browser knows
how to handle that stuff.
So this is really cool.
With other stuff out there,
it's been notoriously
hard to do things like
this because it's all just
a first class citizen
in the browser.
Now you've told the browser
about this demo tabs element,
and it knows how
to deal with that.
Sensibility.
I'm going to go through
this really quickly,
but you saw the maps example.
I actually didn't build
that maps component.
There was a component out
there that somebody had built.
It rendered a map to the screen.
It had nothing to do--
it had no idea about how
to render markers.
But I said, hey, it makes sense
to put markers on a Google Map,
so we should combine that.
So, in Polymer, it's really easy
to-- and in custom elements,
it's really easy
to extend it now.
Just say, hey, extend
the Google Map tag.
And I'm going to create a new
tag called map with markers.
And I'm going to give it
a new API, add to the API
that somebody else gave me,
I'm going to inherit that.
I'm going to
inherit its UI, it's
going to render my map for me.
But I'm just going to
be able to stick the map
markers on the map.
So that's really
cool, because again,
like the message
here is you don't
have to reinvent the wheel.
I didn't care how that map's
API-- that map's component
was made.
I just start using it.
All right, so
that's the universe.
Universe is one that's
declared as composable
and configured via attributes.
And it's using events
and its using DOM.
I think this is really powerful.
This is a cool demo that
I'll just play before I go.
John McCutchan put this
together, it's a WebGL demo,
and used the Polymer.dart port.
He's got, basically,
implemented WebGL
calls using custom
elements and markup.
So you can see what I'm
doing here is in the DevTools
since there's first
class support.
I can edit attributes
and things just
update magically right
in the WebGL scene.
I actually know
nothing about WebGL.
So this is really
cool to me because I
know everything about
JavaScript and HTML.
I can go up and change a texture
of one of these 3D spheres just
by changing an attribute and
it points to a .jpeg file,
and I can change that
to something else.
And now, Web Components is
the center of the universe.
So that's really great,
because he's totally wrapped up
his library and his complex
stuff, and I can just use it.
So that's all I got.
I think this stuff
is really cool.
I think we should all
componentize the web.
Let's join the
revolution together.
That's all for me.
Feel free to Tweet at me and
talk to me after the show.
Appreciate the time, guys.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]